I am so happy here you're hilarious oh
thank you I mean super talented actor I
always loved comedians when they act
like y'all can go so dark or you keep
like heavy or you can go really light
and funny it's it's awesome - yeah I
feel like comedy you have to you know be
able to really act and sell it yeah yeah
it's it's a lot all right well okay do
you have any plans for Valentine's Day
are you one of those uh well that goes
all out you
we definitely eat a lot together always
that's like a state engine why it's my
house yeah we'll just binge and drink
we're drinking wine okay yeah weird girl
white girl just curious red nice you two
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I heard something about you though that
you've always wanted to be a mom right
yes and we are doing IVF right now
actually it sounds like just a process
because so many people go through it now
it's in the process but it's kind of
hardcore I've had friends don't do that
yeah yeah so this Valentine's Day I'll
be getting shots in my butt about my
husband hormones very romantic yes yeah
but the hormones are very intense and
you know so many people they go through
this and you know we don't talk about it
enough I think as women and you know
just we need to raise more understanding
and awareness and I'm glad that's why I
was so happy you wanted to talk about
this day because I have friends went
through and I mean I went through some
serious depression felt shame like was
like what was wrong with me like tried
everything under the Sun and sometimes
it just doesn't happen and you just need
science to kind of help move it along
and it's actually it's such a miracle
what they can do like that's a miracle
and of itself you know um
did you always picture yourself being a
mom yeah definitely you're the baby of
the family and you always wanted kids
we're like opposite you know I'm not I'm
older sis oh you're getting that me God
but I had like a little baby carriage
though you know and a baby dog that was
my sister and then she'd curl my hair
and excellent burned me it was fine
now you're at my sister's bangs your
yeah that's what my sister could do so
your dad is comedian Chris Elliott was
that intimidating for your husband to
like meet the fam oh yeah for sure
yeah there was a hazing period for a
while with yeah and we do this thing in
our family called the ice bucket
challenge but it's not the one for
charity it's not the good one and it's
just a sober us up when we've been
drinking what we do is we all stick our
head in like a bucket of ice to see who
can last the longest in there and then
whoever does win I guess he didn't so my
husband came in to to a wedding actually
was the first time I was introducing him
to my parents and the first time you
introduced your boyfriend to your
parents was it a wedding yeah my cousin
that is Bo yeah yeah yeah and he was
really confident and you know and he has
these like runners lungs and he was
under water for like a solid two minutes
I'm trying to impress my mage died
trying to get water yeah you knew right
then didn't you I did yeah he wants to
win yeah I would be attracted that to me
but tell us about your new show though
indebted indebted it is about baby
boomers played by Fran Drescher and
Steven Weber who lose all their money
and go broke and they have to move in
with their young son and his family and
I play the wife of the son he was super
excited who's super excited to have her
in-laws move in and yeah it's it's a lot
it's so I my characters kind of caught
in the middle of this crazy new family
dynamic that's happening in her in her
house and it's it's a really fun we have
such a great time I love personally both
of your shows I think represent like
actual real conversations that happen be
it funny or serious yeah and I think
that's so important it's fun to watch
and know that like you're not abnormal
that so many families go through all of
those experiences and emotions totally a
show really like dives into you know
what it's like to be a Boomer
you doesn't know how to use technology
and then and then we're the Millennials
who are like uh but we're also learning
from them so we both kind of learn from
each other and my character kind of ends
up liking having them in the house
that's the only part that's not real
life ya know so here's my question - so
you do Meryl Streep impersonations
correct um so I was thinking like in
prep for like when pigs fly and she
actually comes on my show could you show
me the impression could you show us yeah
close your eyes just okay I'm here yeah
she's here I was crying I was laughing
sorry because every picture I do see a
Meryl Streep she has been like most
badass glasses on like they're like
they've got to be like a thousand
dollars they're so cute
and there's like like a like designer
ever yes but what's the glasses it's
what you're so awesome I love you're so
funny so we'll put this on our mural
instapage people you're welcome
so when JA ever or would you ever
because I know you're on has to Nell for
years would you ever host SNL just that
would be like bucket lists for me
honestly yeah yeah yeah so good I could
retire I could retire my job yeah yeah
oh my gosh okay well do you want to
practice and maybe take you yeah I feel
like cue cards are the one thing that
you have to get yeah oh they do that a
lot cuz I've done it we don't need cue
cards you don't use country to practice
definitely don't use a cue cards what
you yeah you yeah it's like an art form
notice in and of itself okay you should
practice with cue cards we have put
cards do you want to take us to break
let's take you to break you know what
challenge accepted here he goes Justin
reads cards
[Laughter]
indebted premieres February 6th on NBC
she needs practice come back we're
getting our lobster roll on I'm crushing
this yes yeah you do not want to miss
this you I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my YouTube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this